you are listening to the hot breath
podcast I am your host comedian Joel
Byers and welcome to your weekly guide
to comedy mastery yeah so thanks for
doing this man absolutely dude we are
all the way out here last time we did
this was number 14 of my podcast episode
14 and now it's we're in the 140s and
what's perfect but this timing is last
time I was out here you were on
Billboard's for a TV show and and then
that long ago and now you're on for the
dog for the dog movie you know it was so
crazy it's like just watching your climb
it's been great man man it's been a trip
it kind of just I was telling like I
don't know couple people walk my mom day
a couple friends and stuff like because
I was I was in Atlanta when we talked
about doing this and write plays I've
cheating a new movie yeah in Atlanta
will Packer production which is also
truth be told was so I hopped in a movie
with Regina Hall ELISA ray
Mikey day I mean just nobody'll yeah
don't cast in Marseille Martin from from
blackish uh-huh who's 13 year old who
executive produced the movie and starred
in it she's amazing man but yeah so it
kind of it was funny like shooting
shooting that and in Atlanta was was
great because I got a chance to be home
and see some people and stuff and then
but also like two days before the movie
came out even after the premiere I kind
of like didn't hit me but I was like
just stoned and my and in my bed hotel
room and it just I was like oh [ __ ] I'm
gonna movie uh-huh
cuz you know just takes forever to come
out you know like I mean the turnaround
isn't always that you know so I mean we
got we did it last we started last
October mm-hmm and just I mean you know
it's kinda like a lead in a movie which
is just Ana's like mob lo event and one
of the things you talked about in the
first interview was just the power of no
as well but you're doing so many
projects so how do you decide what to do
you know what's funny is like I I didn't
I feel like I said man that's a great
question the power of no is because even
after disjointed disjointed was a show
that on Netflix and it got cancelled and
I'm a I got been enough now to know yeah
I felt it happening to me I felt it as
we were shooting and I didn't want to
happen cuz I loved the cast and I loved
that the crew and the staff in the
studio and in the network and they were
amazing but it just felt like something
was often I felt that feeling before and
it's like I'm out I'm gonna keep going
and try to give it a hundred percent but
when stuff just that when when you don't
feel the figuration from them on one
side of it you kind of go okay maybe
when you start playing to feel the
looking for a job huh let me start
writing again but so when it got
cancelled I was in New York I was kind
of living in New York from December to
about March mid into March and a
probably pilot season had started but
you know when you're locked up on a
studio deal
you can't take another job and I knew
the job was going away because other
members of my cast had started getting
other work and I'm like all right I need
to be out oh and then the studio was
holding me back to like try to take one
of their projects and I was like I just
want to read a lot of stuff first before
which is crazy to be in that position
because yet studio pump the brakes you
know for like for like six seven years I
just wanted one script right like hey
man like if you want to offer me this I
don't care I'm gonna [ __ ] what this is
I'll do it and uh and it's champagne
problems man this is really it's a trip
how you know you got to really like step
back and go this is such a blessing to
be offered Matt got nine offers this
year Wow nine straight offers like two
dramas and uh seven comedies and I said
no to eight huh it's like well want one
one I said yes to which is the original
one I really wanted to do because I love
the story and I read it but I didn't
hate I wasn't old enough to play what
they were going for mm-hmm but it was
written for somebody with my temperament
my drama and comedy skillset and they
dude who got it was like I'm a fan of
and I was like if I don't get this
please he has to do this so I'm Alvis I
mean when I read it I was like that
makes sense I mean just you know
proud of him and and he's a good dude
with a much buddy yeah he's um he
deserves he's a great actor
getting all these offers like even just
like even like on our on our level of
like in our how well we know each other
you were willing even to Atlanta we were
like trying to schedule a time to meet
up and do this while you're on set and
then now we're out in LA and you're
willing to carve out this time and just
being so generous is that and kind is
that something you attribute to your
success over the years uh yeah I think
I'm uh for the most part pretty reliable
pretty dependable mm you know feel like
I've gotten to be more of a realistic
truth teller
I mean uh no problem saying I can't I
mean I used to be and not that I'd still
don't do this because I mean I do but I
used to be that guy that said yes to
everything is I don't want to disappoint
people and sometimes you just can't so I
mean that's also a no to get used to
because I think we all want to make sure
that if you care about somebody I care
about somebody's passion your dream that
you want to be able to assist if they
things you help but it was uh I mean I
think you know like people looked out
for me and I look at the guys who helped
me and then I mean there were guys I've
known since I was 17 who were doing
comedy especially in Atlanta before I
even thought about doing comedy who I
keep up with now yeah and I mean one is
writing on this lot for a show and it is
Sean Larkins yeah so yeah yeah I've
known him since I was in high school and
it's it's it's really cool too when I
started out asking him for advice and
then now he'll call and go you know man
like what do you think about this can i
and it's because I have had some more of
the business side you know of learning
of learning how it works like the pieces
and I'm really dumb even then they're
you're just inside of me like I'll make
suggestions and like the directors like
yeah but see if that works I mean like I
have no problem cuz cuz I Victor
Gonzalez who's directing this episode is
I put them to the side hey man I want to
just shadow you at some point to learn
how to direct because I want to hop into
this at some point huh and so you know
we talked about shots and and movements
and blocking and yesterday when we were
doing I was like I think it makes just
if you don't mind you make more sense
for if we cross on this line I go around
here and then we come back he goes I
mean it might work it might not who know
the see and then he goes it works for me
and I got a chance you know
you know my invisible invisable
directing hat on just for a second but
it's like okay at least I'm thinking in
those terms but yeah I mean I don't know
it's you don't want to be disliked in
this business and it's not an
ass-kissing thing is like well what if
we just made each other's lives easier
like that to be there be easier than
holding each other back or being him
that crabs in a barrel mentality I mean
there's so much content out here now
that I mean we can all work yeah you
know and you've said Hollywood it's like
the world's smallest high school man the
the when I was in New York for those
couple months man it was like I was
living in cold LA oh yeah I mean it
still is still the same thing instead of
same thing I mean the LA New Yorker
closer in proximity than st. Louis
Chicago the miles might be more vast but
the there's it's it's not like you made
a mistake along the way and what a no I
just I mean I mean you just you just
don't know how you can't imagine how
quick if you're you're living in Middle
American you have a 9:00 to 5:00 and you
you know the rumor mill or just people
talking or whatever happens to you like
that in an office in LA it's in
Hollywood bubble of what the
entertainment city is it just you have
no none of your own business huh and
it's like and I'm not a I don't really
promote a lot of my personal life I mean
like it's people who know me know what
I'm doing and like you know things
around me but I don't I don't put like
my personal life out there on social
media much because I don't I do like my
alone time you know I get slice I won't
post for a week or two because I'm
living you know I won't but people tell
you you'll get your letter New Yorker
then I go to a club or like have dinner
something this amaizing heard you and
you're like it just wow like I just hung
up and then you ask me about how did you
find out he's crazy uh people uh I mean
the chatter then what kind of tips do
you have for people the best way to
navigate that world
I don't may not cuz I don't know I mean
you know you see those people like you
know who
you know they moved back to you know you
get something going you move out of town
I mean that's I plan on it I plan on
leaving town when I mean you know we get
a season two on this show then I'm out
keep my apartment here and then move
somewhere else and just because it is it
is uh is a little draining man always
and I wouldn't say having to be on but
there's a there's a and I'm not the dude
who's always on you know that got you
know there's some comics some actors who
you ever talk to actor and they I mean I
got a friend from home this you just do
any time we talk it's like she's in a
scene we try that again and I you know
she's good people I've known her for
over ten years but it's such a it's such
a silly thing and I remember I do
remember like being a young act like
before I started comedy like doing some
stuff in Atlanta and then all of us were
always like working on our craft but
then to be 1012 years past that and then
now I know how to like oh let me take a
break I got to turn it on in there 15
minutes for a run-through mm-hmm where's
like here's like oh we're gonna talk but
right I talked to her last week as she
came on set and she was just like I am
just you have no idea the passion and
the pride in the and the happiness that
I'm like who are you talking and and
it's it's kind of sad but the same times
like I know why you're doing it was like
but you don't have to prove that you got
skills for me yeah that's it similarly I
always help you if I could yeah people
can feel authenticity and it's I mean
people do it here all the time
but people become that character hmm you
know yeah yeah that's like that's which
is fine if that's how you've been
forever
then maybe that's who you are so like
great but there's a I mean you can you
know it's it's a I guess the best
example I have like if you ever seen if
you ever seen which everybody should
have at least seen one Eddie Murphy
movie in any Murphy goes so hard and
everything he does regardless if it's
you know if it's a blockbuster hit or if
it doesn't do well or if it's an indie
whatever it is Eddie has a great pulse
on when I'm
working I'm working and he's a naturally
funny dude but you ever watch him on a
late-night catcher during interview he's
very chill yeah it's like I'm not making
millions to make you laugh right now
I mean you know something funny comes
out then cool but we came to talk about
this I didn't come to do a concert and
so I've had to like retrain myself to to
do it because even my publicist said
once you say I'll get you on his thing
and you'll you know ask some question
you'd be funny stuff and I was like I
don't really work like that
if it happens to be cool and funny then
great but I got to remember who I am
and go you know if it gets to that
because you remember those clips are
like Robin Williams were like they would
just go with it oh my god
turn it on oh yeah and it's like I mean
eventually you know you get sick of you
said gets it going like that's all for
me mmm-hmm that was a great documentary
too like he felt like unless he was
alone he couldn't turn off because like
that's what people like being around him
it's like nobody a lot of you really
didn't know who he was with all the heat
you have right now and more and more
people figuring out who you are like
have you had to switch up your game or
are you looking you will you admit you'd
won to retire by the time you were 41
yeah yeah before and it you mentioned
talking to your director and being like
I want to look into that more is that
like you're starting to look at the next
esa like retire i mean like the grind of
acting hmm and but you know but if like
if you turn into a director and had like
a dope like film that you wrote and you
were like tone I think you'd be great
for this part I mean yeah but the
waiting with 30 of the do's and audition
rooms and in the I mean it's just his
soul draining you know I think that
hustle dude and they're in there
you know you get casting directors that
are amazing you get some that are shitty
they're like they treat you like a you
know it's treated like a [ __ ] like
you're nothing and then you see him out
and go like hey how you doing you're
like nah mitri my aspect here but then
if you do get the part then they go
thank you so much for joining it's like
couldn't you be a little more cordial in
the big there's a way to do this and so
it's a it's hard to have friends here
because like I mean people that you
didn't start with those you know like
yeah you're cool as long as you working
as soon as you don't have a job for two
or three years nobody's a [ __ ] about
your sake
that it you know I mean like that yeah
it's like uh it's like being in college
and in it you know the fourth the cool
you know the four guys you hang out with
one drops out and you want to still be
cool with it but like this we don't have
the same stories anymore it's like you
wanted to get back in college so like
you don't cuz you don't want to leave
him behind
mm-hmm but it's like you chose a
different path and I don't I mean we'll
catch up when we catch up but like you
know what the reason why were friends in
the first place is the first place is
because we had this commonality and now
we don't so you know where do we go from
here yeah and it looks like you're
looking to even get behind the camera
now is where you're here I mean I'd like
to I mean you know just you know working
on more stuff and the multicam thing and
just you know diving into that there's a
guy by the name of Richie Keane who
directed my special day in Showtime
Congrats man yeah
Congrats on that who like was a comic an
actor and then now a director and we
ready okay cool oh yeah you don't do
that dear no 15 20 minutes afterwards
yes do it all right take two back at it
on I met before we have we have hot
breath water now to a breath water is
your to our local water sponsor 'fantasy
man that that's I mean that's so you
want water call hot breath all the way
up there girl monday 6:00 a.m. oh the
grind 6:00 a.m. baby something is gonna
be light I've seen I've seen like TV
shows taped but to actually see the
behind the scenes like I have today is
really cool to see it all the way from
the rehearsal to then what did you just
do the predator producer run-through so
is that all the writers and writers and
producers are some folks from the
network and studio come and they have
their notes and then so that's that's
like a third of the people that might be
there on Monday and Tuesday okay and
then we'll shoot a little bit on Tuesday
and then shoot the rest live on
Wednesday and it seemed even just
watching the rehearsal and then seeing
it with the producer run-through seemed
like everybody was on their lines more
in terms of like knowing them and like
you just don't the hard part is like you
can set it as much as you want but
having the script in your hand because
you don't know because it changes all
the time they go to rewrite give it back
to you do rewrite give it back to you
and so you think you know exactly where
laugh is gonna be or how someone's going
but then if if a joke drops or lands
harder than you expect then it throws
off the next piece and if somebody can
jump your line you can't go back as
you're timing it so I guess so it
definitely is not it's like it's mostly
for the writers to go all right we need
tighten this up or take that out or
whatever and then actors to go because
it's not really on us yet Tuesday is
when it goes when they go okay this is
it's done
gotcha to work uh-huh and so uh so yeah
I mean like that that to me that wasn't
a good one for me
but also I mean that's in my opinion to
me I'm sure it's fine but I just hold
myself to a higher standard but also I'm
trying to make stuff jokes that aren't
written as jokes and stuff that is only
set up and really I mean super Hollywood
talk right now no but as a comedian you
want the laugh yeah yeah you have to you
have to know when and sometimes the
laugh is the reaction true you know so
it's not it's like setup punch and then
there's another punch after you know
facial expression whatever so just
trying to get those beats down and
letting them know I mean some I mean I
do have a I'm in a position sometimes
where they give me stuff that's unmolded
where they give everybody else stuff
that's like complete and they go but
he'll figure it out I know you think I'm
gonna figure this out but let me see it
first so I can change change this and
give it give it to everyone how I think
I would do it so I could change the
words up so I know the direction let me
do this how I know it would work which
is what I'll do to say Wednesday no
matter what because once it's lies it
doesn't matter I mean I'm on my own
terms so when the audience is there if I
want to try something do it on my own
that's just what's gonna happen it's
taken ownership and like the surprise
for them too is also like pretty funny
what's your technique for analyzing a
script when you get it and then also
memorizing the lines just repetition on
the memorizing I mean you never know
what the audience is gonna find really
funny if you know if you're supposed to
put a glass down and it tips over water
goes everywhere you can still save the
scene but unless you just call cut
yourself or whatever I've always found
that because I'm I guess I guess I would
say I was an actor before like before
I'm when I was in Atlanta still before I
moved to Dallas I'm out doing some
smaller part you know some smaller indie
stuff and just stuff around town
products around town but now my process
is to watch all the actors work first
like Nina's done this before she hasn't
done a sitcom but she likes to break
down the script her own way you know
Brian Stokes Mitchell who Brian mature
Stokes
what I keep doing that Mitchell right
soaks right I keep I keep it I keep
flipping fumble if you're asking your
assistant why you can't get someone why
are you getting his name right why can't
I do that on that to-do list and then
Shelly rhyme in there you know does
they've been any game for 40 years and
they know exactly what they're doing and
so I like to let them set what they do
first and then I can figure out my joke
around that and if it's just a setup or
if it's a straight line from a straight
man then it's not that it's not the you
know you everybody can't be the straight
man everybody can be the comic you know
you ruined stuff everybody trying to
outdo each other yeah so you have to
know if I'm if you're set up your set up
so I just I just say you know I'm throat
you Dahlia so you can bring home I let
them do that first and then I implement
like where I think might be funny or
what I want to do okay and sometimes I
don't tell them what I'm gonna do in
depends of what director that is to some
directors I mean I've had directors go
are you saving it I'm Mikey I don't want
to do it right now and they're like all
right all right that's rescue
interesting and if some people go like
we tell me what you're about to do I
mean when I did the movie a little for
will Packer last week I mean literally
there are a couple scenes where the
director goes like you weren't saying
anything in the scene but you got any
ideas I'm like what interesting yeah oh
my gay I got something like oh yeah I
throw that in there it's fine
and I end up pulling out five six miles
of the scene then I really I was
supposed to be walking passing in and
out of it ends up being funny we in you
know it's it's it's uh it's nice to be
in that position because six years ago I
couldn't do that seven years ago I
wasn't even in front anybody's camera so
now getting a chance to help out and be
a part of the process is uh it's great
that's what's gonna ask is like now that
you you seem to have a little bit more
leverage in the game and people maybe
trust your opinion is maybe when you're
new or they're like just say the line
really
yeah I mean just for like what nobody
knows your career like what you've been
doing it's like I'm a comic and I have a
delivery but people go like no you're an
actor you're like okay but then
directors who when they feel like they
have to do their research and respect
you a little more as a performer they go
okay so they watch clips online and you
know my manager will send them a piece
of piece of my special or something and
indigo okay so this is how he might
change words because I know I say
certain words funny enough that it means
the same thing but I'll break I just had
my own sterilizer on Stein yeah if I
they would do stuff I miss like giving
Bill Bellamy and Chris it's like they
don't if we talked about this last time
but I heard a podcast with Bill Bellamy
where he was attached to play man was
the character's name he supposed to be
in money talks they bailed me was
playing money talks with with Charlie
Sheen and Brett Ratner was directing how
to be a player in the studio put Brett
Ratner on money talks
so he took Chris Tucker who was supposed
to be in how to be a player to money
talks and then they'd switch Bill
Bellamy over to how to be a play but
both those are hilarious crazy yeah
they're both hilarious so imagine what
money talks would have been if it were
with Bill Bellamy we could all say my oh
no we love Chris Tucker but we don't
know what does with me right everybody
has their own and they respect both
comics you have so much insight in the
last interview you were talking about
how the show Modern Family start out
being about a foreign exchange student
right and he tested bad you told us all
about the rating system in TV yeah and
you also said something about how you
got one time like a hundred sixty
thousand dollar check there being like
19 grand I love that story I hate that
story but I love that story I'm like you
talk about like if you if you ever watch
like 30 for 30 broke yeah all the NFL
players and and you think you have money
and I mean what do you think you make it
doesn't matter what that chick says
you're getting a fifth of it it's crazy
it's crazy I mean so like I mean when
people see check stubs laying around the
house you see like multiple zeroes you
like [ __ ] man you made it you like
that's not the right amount
that I mean between you know you given
up 65% every time you get paid you know
it's looking like right now in your
career you know I'm thinking about Nina
is starring in the show where we're
taping right now and also in the movie
you were in
yeah it seems like seems like Tom Bell
has the machine behind him right now
he's brewing okay let's see let's see
I mean I'm excited for this new I have
another film at the Toronto
International Film Festival and it's
supposed to be I haven't seen that one
either but it's supposed to be good
mm-hmm so we'll see what happens yeah I
mean you know stuff is I feel like I
felt like things keep going this well
then you know I'll be in that up next
you know in that category of that list
of guys or people that might have a shot
to to uh to be memorable and have a good
career yeah it's I mean if there it was
that in like Hollywood strategy is it
like okay they're starting to movie
together we should put a man TV show
together like is that that was just like
well I got cast last in Dog Days in by
the time Nina and I met and started
working together like we just kind of
cuz all of our scenes were at least the
first few were in order so we actually
were meeting for the first time in the
movie and in life hmm and so it kind of
was very organic and and then when it
when it came to the show I've tested
with probably three or four other
actresses and which were all great they
really were great and they're very funny
something didn't match up an age some
didn't have multicam experience some
were trying to win everything sometimes
it's not for your seat it's not your
scene to win mm-hmm
as far as like who who who needs a scene
for this storyline to continue or to to
resolve in this manner so we can wrap it
back around for the resolution of the
show so some people don't have that and
and unfortunately they didn't for that
test and we didn't work together or
getting used to each other so and I'd
already accepted the job and insan doing
and then as they were looking for
someone they go like well you know they
worked together on the movie and so we
didn't have to audition or test or
anything together they just had scenes
from the movie over and and we're like
yeah man they work if she says
yeah then do you want to work with her
and then she calls me and then I was
like you know I love working with you so
if if you're down I'm down yeah and she
was like I just don't want to be still
gonna show people that I'm like well you
know you got to make that decision but I
think this is you know I won't let you
fail and I won't I'm pretty easy to work
with and you asked me a question you
know I'd rather be happy for six years
six eight seasons then miserable so I
want to come I want to come to work and
you know the more seasons that go on I'm
trying to get that big bang money if
they happen the syndication I mean I
mean ten million dollars an episode that
ain't that's adding bad that's where
they're at oh yeah well at least three
or four of them well I mean I think the
least I think that the least someone
makes on that show is like 315 335
thousand is that a million and then the
65 is gone though that's still that's 65
percent right yeah so ever so I mean
which ain't bad money but still which
there's three hundred thousand dollars
in episode yet you get to pocket is not
you know I can't but the public hears oh
he's getting a million Epis I mean it's
like back in the nineties when people
were getting 20-minute of a 20 minute
movie sounds unbelievable and it is
unbelievable but you only bring home six
eight if you ever feel lucky if you're
lucky you know if you know some Trump
skills on on how to write holes maybe
bring home ten who knows but I can't see
nobody nobody gets a check for 20 and
keeps 20 maybe Bill Murray cuz bill has
they just call him oh yeah but I don't
think bill is getting xx these days but
like he probably keeps all his money
because he said he's earned that keep
though like well he just is like you
want me you want me do this part leave a
a voicemail on my answering machine
and he'll check it and do the project
well I think maybe private just gets
checked straight ridden him oh that's
what he does no he just has a voicemail
people book come on oh that's what he's
been doing for since the 80s from what I
hear so you did ran out so I'm talking
like I'm friends with Bill Miriam yeah
you are talking about industry insight
man so we'll land this plane here but
you mentioned just then referred to is
that others drugs no this is just this
is b12
[Music]
and here in this la life yeah so well
baby beets well so you refer to a second
ago you feel like you're almost at a
point now where you're getting poised to
make an impact in this and be one of
those like influencers like you said you
use that word but what in making that
impact what do you see that impact being
uh I mean I don't know I mean like it's
you know it's I like TV I mean I haven't
done that many films to know if I really
like cuz I mean being on a being on a
film set is very Harappan wait yeah and
you know if you're not the focal point
of it yeah you're very much hurry up and
wait but uh I'm a still a lot of fun
though because I most of the time
especially if you have cool co-stars you
get a chance to learn about each other
especially if there's people that you
admire and that you've been wanting to
work with or dreamt about working with
and I think those are the best things
cuz outside of that you know you're Tom
Cruise and if he happens to be cool and
then you know we have lunch together and
he goes man it was yeah alright so then
his next movie goes remember the kid
they had a small part in that thing like
we should see if he and that always goes
I mean that's than anything now I mean
that's just that's just cordiality
amongst people so yeah you know to have
a have a you know that's reputation I
don't think is what I'm trying to say
but to have it could have reputation and
just people want to work with you and
you know you I think you want to leave
the game not the perception of like a
Lohan from years ago but like I'm sure
that she just lost a grasp of my man on
or so I can't really talk for what she
went through but I mean she was super
like Lindsay Lohan so Lindsay was like
super super young and you know the whole
world is at your fingertips you know and
and then when you feel like everything's
going your way and then stuff kind of
stops going your way you know who do you
transition to who you want to I mean
dude that's why I still to have a Prius
yeah she keeps me very humble I don't
want I don't wanna start living that you
know people always like me he don't want
to pull up on the lot like a boss and
I'm like no I want the boss to think I
need a job boom yeah yeah hey man it's
toasters driving a Prius man we got to
get him some more money and you
mentioned earlier in the interview about
talking to the director and like wanting
to get in that more is that are you
thinking that's the impact you want to
make as well
I mean yeah it's it's if I when that
spark comes is like I do want you have
either cassette turned out to dramas
I've turned down multiple dramas of like
the last few years and one was in Hawaii
one was in Toronto there was one I was
gonna shoot in South Africa that I
didn't turn down but it was kind of it
was pulled for me by a studio and but
not maliciously it was just like they
had another idea and so I kind of didn't
know what was going on but it end up
working out anyway you know you just
want to I want to have fun man I mean
there's you know Kevin Hart said
something like a while ago when his
interviews where people keep asking them
to they want to do something dramatic
and he's like a Jim I'm just getting a
chance to star in comedies I like you
got to chase the art later you know I'm
a chases comedy and then the art will
find you so I'm sure you got that advice
from somebody else and I mean and I was
kind of doing that without ever hearing
that people like you want to do this
drama I'm like yeah I know if I got on
NCIS the Kansas City that it probably
last for ten seasons and I make some
great money but it's like is that the
career that I want yeah you vote me
nobody goes at a comedy club to to go
see to do from CSI I still want to do
stand-up so my thing is like I want to
conquer comedy first before I get into
that I mean I think then it's Larry did
a good job with that Jamie Foxx I think
did a great job with that like let me do
this first and the human he went back to
music and drama but he was like let me
get this comedy thing off now and then
when you respect me for that something
will come up where you let me I mean
even to joining it was a great vehicle
for me because people find that I could
I wasn't just silly I could do drama
yeah
so I'm getting a little more drama looks
now so hopefully one of these next
projects is a little more physical
because I'd love to play you know
undercover cop or like something
military or whatever but you know I got
to do what I need to do now to go man I
got an anthology of work I mean cuz
right now I've man I probably have done
like over 70 or 80 episodes of
television in seven years mostly playing
a regular or some sort of arc on
something never like a co-star or guest
star which is great but nothing has been
like I'm carrying a character for
multiple years which I'd like to try to
get into mm-hmm you know so that's at me
is I mean that's
I mean you know I I got other dreams too
but and not that I'm not writing on the
side but right now it's like so I can
have that respect level of you know when
Aaron capital whoo-hoo Capital
Entertainment produces the show in the
studio with CBS on the show I mean he's
in a position to go okay
I've see you've been grinding out last
two three years you got anything and
then I can sit with him as talent and
probably a producer and go I want to
produce it with you and then he has more
of a reason to take me seriously on
something other than being talent the
vision man so it's you know the vision
is even when when we interviewed each
other when any of you do a few years ago
and you were like you know at one time I
had an opportunity to sit on the panel
of a Fallon here like I turned it down
because that's not where I that's not
how I wanted that first time - yeah yeah
like you just this organic seems like
your careers been very organic and that
seems almost be an x-factor yeah I mean
some stuff you don't want to do but it's
like is this a means to an end like I I
kind of turn this thing I turn this show
down I hosted this awards show a few
months ago you know two or three
thousand people in New York and I got
the offer to do it three years prior it
was here in LA and they offered me I
think like six grand and do it and it
was down the street and it was like man
six grand two hours of work okay but
that kind of was a feeling I was like
man something now why I'm a wait then he
asked me the next year they offered me
like 6,500 I was like 500 why should
they offer me seven which was this year
um and then I was like I've done two
movies since all three really I'm one
win strict like Showtime on demand and I
was like nah I think I'm good man want
to go out of New York for like seven
grand which is crazy to things like I'm
not you go like now like I was like they
should give me some more than they came
back with 25 like that up I'll take yeah
yeah let's do that
oh yeah that's that's here we go and
then but I think they take me I think
they took me a little more seriously
here and they already have kind of like
hey we got something coming up an answer
named Amsterdam we have one in Rome so
we'll check your schedule see if you
were you're free but also I think I was
better suited for it I mean I've hosted
couple more things and then and so I was
a better talent to know what they wanted
more and then I would have been two
years ago when they asked me the first
time yeah and that perceived value goes
a long way too
so that's let's get out of here cuz I
know your time is very valuable but no
25 before we get out of here is there
anything else you want the world to know
I still drive a Prius and I still Rock
cassia why does I don't want people
asking me for money
hey don't ask dumbbell for money don't
ask me for money well thanks for doing
this yeah absolutely all ways absolutely
my man keep up the good work give him
one of those rent watch famil CBS and
once go watch dog days and look out for
the weekend it's a movie I did I look
out for hits a party and some other you
know comedy knockout and all the small
stuff I got going outside of that but
yeah okay social media website all my
special coming out in October my
Showtime special is can't say what's
called what's up can't cancel this
[Laughter]
that's perfect I'm telling you you know
the life [ __ ] seven canceled shows
man I got to make fun of myself but the
stock is rising my man absolutely man
all right we enjoy your Bert yeah happy
birthday by the way yeah yeah yeah thank
you thank you thank you yes Mannie yes
hey man birthday is just another day you
gotta keep working keep working
I mean I will go have fun tonight man I
appreciate you after those they still
don't bail
I breath